we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p really funny
voicemail and the voice mail gets cut
off okay but i'd want to try to figure
out where was this voicemail going
before it was cut off i think you'll
understand once you hear it
i David this is Xavier from Colorado I
just wanted to express to you why it is
so important for us to to legalize ranch
and then it goes silent and lasts about
another 45 seconds during I assume which
the the caller was talking but it didn't
come through legalize ranch are they
talking about legalizing Ranch Dressing
are they talking about legalizing some
kind of ranching in some state I have
absolutely no idea what this where this
could have been going and it's it's
disappointing but it was cut off when it
did we need to talk about legalizing
ranch I genuinely have no clue what that
could be so if you have a sense please
get in touch and let me know and if
you're the caller please call back
because that's all we got and I know
that you were on the phone another 45 or
50 seconds and the rest of it didn't
come through so call back in and we will
absolutely follow up on it on today's
bonus show some states allow using
sunscreen at school without a doctor's
permission is that controversial in some
ways apparently it is and we're going to
talk about it on the bonus show number
two India is making history by employing
transgender people in government jobs
why is this historic what is the broader
situation in which transgender people
are living in India we will talk about
that on the bonus show and also you've
heard of alt right you've heard of
regressive left you've probably heard of
Chuck have you heard of the white left
the white left is a very popular insult
that is used on Chinese forums on the
internet among Chinese users we will
talk about what it means we will talk
about why it is being used and why it's
been popularized on today's bonus show
how do you get the bonus show the bonus
show is a daily program it's an extra
show in addition to our broadcast show
we do the bonus show every day for our
paid members so they access the bonus
show and all of the other member
benefits you go to david pakman.com
slash membership if you want a discount
by all means take the discount by using
the coupon code
I voted seventeen and you can also make
a pledge of any amount even a dollar a
month helps to defray the lost revenue
due to due to the YouTube ad pocalypse
problem we're dealing with you can make
a pledge at patreon.com slash david
pakman show will speak to you on the
bonus show